You've talked about the difference
between intelligence and wisdom.
Jason Clark,
you have talked about the difference
between intelligence and wisdom saying
intelligence isn't a shortcut to wisdom.
Well,
let's,
let's point something else out,
man.
Stupidity isn't a
shortcut to wisdom either.
What is your definition of wisdom?
Okay.
Well,
there's the Old Testament view.
That's the fear of God is
the beginning of wisdom.
That's a good one.
I think wisdom is in part the willingness
to come to terms the knowledge of your
own capacity for malevolence.
That's wisdom.
The the desire to rectify that.
The wish to set the world on a pathway
that leads it closer to have it and
farther away from hell.
That's wisdom.
The humility to know that there's more
things that you don't know then that you
know and that you should be open to what
you don't know when people inform you
of it because it's better to learn that
it is to walk nose first into a wall or
blind folded off a cliff.
Okay.
The knowledge that you don't have the
right to be a judge of being without
having given it your utmost.
That's wisdom.
Wisdom.
What else?
The knowledge.
Wisdom is also the knowledge that hell
is real enough so that you should do
everything you can to avoid either
inhabiting it or producing it.
That's what I learned from,
from psychological analysis of
the history of the 20th century.
Hell's real enough and,
and you,
you're,
you're duty bound.
Let's say your honor bound,
you're ethically bound to do the opposite
of whatever produces those hellish
circumstances.
Okay.